hey y'all i'm me ann i just wrapped on
the drew barrymore show i'm wearing a
little bit of makeup on right now but
not too much i'm going out to dinner
with a friend so i'm going to do a
little bit of jujing before we go
i'm getting a mirror here
so i can like see
all right one cat eye on
and this is nice because it instantly
kind of
wakes you up
[Music]
all right did they match i don't know if
they match we're gonna go with it a
little bit of mascara just a little bit
just to fluff up those lashes just a tad
and then something that i really like
doing
when my base is already done but i've
been wearing it for a few hours i'll
take a little bit of a highlighter
and just refresh the high points of my
cheekbones and give it a little bit more
sheen
instantly kind of wakes your skin up
and i'm running a little late as per
usual so i'm going to take this last
step on the go
all right so last but not least i have a
lip and cheek cream here that i'm going
to put on my cheeks handy little mirror
kind of wake up the skin a little more
you could powder over your skin after
this but it's so cold in new york right
now i don't really feel like i need it
and i will
elevators here i mean it's a college
take a little bit of the last the same
cream
on the lips for a little bit of a
monochromatic
lip and cheek look
and that's it
[Music]